and now let's take a look at Original
Screenplay here are the nominees Eric
Warren singer and David O'Russell for
American hustle Woody Allen and the blue
Jasmine meet Craig Horton and Melissa
Wallach for Dallas buyers club Spike
Jonze for her Bob Nelson for Nebraska
and the Oscar goes to Spike Jonze
including
spike jonze and his first
thank you very much this is an amazing
moment I appreciate it
I have 42 seconds to speak so I better
hurry
the I'm not up here alone I'm up here
with all of my friends and family who
support me and help me make what we make
everybody many of them in the room but
they're all up here in this room up on
the stage with me right now and I that I
appreciate everyone there's vojta he's
over there laughing next to Robert
DeNiro there's a Natalie crying Brian's
smiling Megan Ellison who's very shy she
was hiding in the back it's all of my
friends all everyone that I love that we
made a movie about relationships and
intimacy and that's what we share
together and so this is for all of us up
here and thank you guys for this